the first thing i googled was how to
teach a guy without arms to shoot a bow
and there's nothing out there like that
because it's such a rare thing
my name is matt sussman
i'm from fairfield iowa
and i'm a professional archer
well that's how i shoot there you go in
1982 i was born as you see me right now
without any arms
i never see
not having arms as a limitation it's
amazing how
your body when it's missing something
your other limbs take off and kind of
pick up the slack so for me my feet are
my hands everything that i have in my
life i do with my toes it's pretty rare
that i don't use my feet for something
my phone for example how i pick up my
phone i'd actually grab it with my foot
and flip it and catch it and be like
hello
when i got started shooting it took me
about two weeks from looking at a bow
till shooting probably my first arrow
because i had to figure out how to hold
it with this toe or this toe or this
foot or that foot i had to kind of think
outside the box and come up with some
creative ways of shooting
i actually hold the bow with my right
foot but i will pretend it's somebody's
right arm
in my mind and then i have a release day
that goes over my right shoulder and
actually hook that onto the string
and when i sit up i push my foot away
from my chest which draws the bow at
this point i'm aiming i don't see a guy
without arm shooting i see somebody with
arm shooting and i guess it's just how i
imagine it
so i did repetitions i sat in a chair
for eight hours a day six days a week
time kind of
slows way down you forget who's around
you you forget what you're doing almost
and you're so focused on one thing
shot and shot and shot and shot and shot
that's all i did this bow right here
probably has a million arrows shot
through it at the end of the day you
know helps you become good
a couple
medals or trophies that stand out to me
is my paralympic silver medal i also
have the guinness world record for the
longest accurate archery shot and i shot
an arrow and hit a target from 310 yards
away
i want my kids to see that no matter
what the challenge is you can overcome
it you just have to put your head down
and push through and figure out a way to
be successful figure out a way to just
you know be a good person while you do
all that stuff at the end of the day i
just want to be the best in the world i
don't care if you have arms you don't
have arms i don't care if you were the
michael jordan of the sport and you're
an able-bodied archer i just want to
beat you because i want to be known as
the best archer in the world
you